hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well William James
essay the will to believe has to do with
a number of different kinds of belief
but in particular centers on religious
belief all of the argument and
exposition that he has been engaging in
throughout the essay as well as the many
examples that he has been providing are
culminating in his position in the end
that we we ought to be able and free to
decide for ourselves whether to believe
in what he calls the religious
hypothesis and there's there's certain
conditions involved with this he doesn't
want to embrace any sort of you know
what we might call rank superstition all
right he says that sad experience makes
me fear that some of you may still
shrink from radically saying with me in
abstract or that we have the right to
believe at our own risk any hypothesis
that is live enough to tempt our will
why because the freedom to believe what
we will can be applied to the case of
some patent superstition but James says
if we put that stuff aside when it comes
to religious questions
we do in fact have the right to decide
for ourselves and it's not irrational to
do so it's not any more irrational than
the blanket requirement that we subject
religious belief to something like
scientific verification or absolute
evidence provided through philosophical
argument James says that that would
itself be an irrational stance that many
people are imposing and he has as an
example of somebody who has this sort of
stance William Clifford who said that we
should never believe anything anywhere
on insufficient evidence that to do so
is wrong therefore believing in religion
is is wrong because there isn't any such
evidence so that's all sort of
background to where James is heading he
tells us something about the religious
belief or the religious hypothesis he
says that science says that things are
morality says some things are better
than other things
by contrast religion says essentially
two things what is it that religion
asserts here he's engaging in a bit of
abstraction about religions in general
says first she says that the best things
are the more eternal things the as he
calls them overlapping things the things
in the universe that throw the last
stone so to speak and say the final word
so the things that are really
determinative the things that are
foundational he says perfection is
eternal this phrase of Charles secretin
seems a good way of putting this first
affirmation of religion and notice what
he says an affirmation which obviously
cannot yet be verified scientifically at
all we can't use the means of science to
decide what in fact are the eternal
overlapping and determinative things it
doesn't mean that we can't have any
notion of these or we can't verify it in
other ways the second thing that he know
that he says the second proposition is
that we are better off even
now if we believe her first affirmation
to be true so we're better off if we
believe that statement to be true that
the best things are eternal overlapping
and determinative and so the one is a
claim about you know value order things
along those lines the second one is a
statement about what is good for us as
human beings now you may not recognize
most forms of religion in this rather
stripped-down way of expressing it but
this is what James thinks is really at
the essence of religion and it's good to
keep in mind that James himself had a
lot of experience with religion and
religious people and did in fact give
the lectures the varieties of religious
experience so he's not just doing
armchair pontificating he is he's saying
things that he thinks are really at the
core of genuine religious belief not
just mummery or you know religion and
social control or anything like that now
he goes on and he says let's consider
what the logical elements of this
situation are in case the religious
hypothesis in both its branches be
really true remember a option has to
have two hypotheses so if we want to say
that you know there's a religious
question right or that there's a
religious hypothesis that we have to
consider there have to be two sides to
the option what are the nature of these
so first he says that we must admit the
possibility at the outset if we're going
to discuss the question at all it must
involve a living option and here we
might think back to some of the
assertions that he made at the beginning
his crowd was a Protestant school where
he is giving this lecture and he says
that you know be a Christian or be an
agnostic these are live options for you
be a theosophist or be a Muslim not so
much now if you're in a place where
there's a lot of Muslim belief and
there's a you know mosque gia - right
down the road and you can study with
that you know
well that starts to become a live option
for you right or I don't know if you
hang out with the Theosophists wherever
they happen to be or whatever group
those are live options for you options
are live or dead relative to to us so
what might be a live option for me might
not actually be a live option for you
I'll mention just as an example of this
when I was in graduate school having
grown up in the Midwest where people you
know generally either were some you know
form of religion in the sense of
identifying with a religious
organization going to service is having
some beliefs or they you know had
rejected those beliefs or they were
agnostic or something like that it was a
genuine surprise to me to meet a fellow
graduate student who had grown up in
Southern California and had grown up in
such a secular environment that he
really was bemused about what religious
people thought they were up to I had
never really encountered what you might
call a cultural secularist like that
where it would just these weren't live
options for him at all you know for me I
could you know go back to the church or
reject the church or pick some other
denomination or you know embrace some
something else but for him none of those
things they actually made sense they
weren't live options so religion offers
us a possibility if it is indeed a live
option in the form that we're looking at
he also goes on and he says here we go
we see that religion offers itself as a
momentous option what is a momentous
option if we don't take the option we
miss out on something we can't go back
and point you to that point in time and
redo it or find similar options
occurring later on so he says we're
supposed to gain even now by our belief
and to lose by our non belief a certain
vital good that makes it a momentous
option but he says religion is also a
force
options so far as that good goes we
can't escape the issue by remaining
skeptical and waiting for more light
because although we do avoid error in
that way if religion be untrue we lose
the good if it be true just as certainly
as if we positively chose to disbelieve
it's as if a person should hesitate
indefinitely to ask a certain woman to
marry him because he was not perfectly
sure that she would prove an angel after
he brought her home very unrealistic
expectations of marriage right there
would he not cut himself off from that
particular angel possibility as
decisively as if he went and married
someone else so James goes on and he
says skepticism is not the avoidance of
option it's actually taking an option so
religion offers itself to at least some
of us under its its various guises or
modes as a living momentous and forced
option between hypotheses and it's good
to remember that James by this point has
established that when we have such a
genuine option such as that and it can't
be decided by intellectual means alone
he says that not only may we decided
based on our passional nature or a
volitional nature that is by willing by
deciding we must do so we must do so one
way or the other
and so James is making the argument that
to forbid that as many people who argue
against religion do or caution against
throwing yourself in or taking a leap of
faith are engaged in doing is actually a
illegitimate stance to take she says to
preach skepticism to us as duty until
sufficient evidence for reason for
religion be found is tantamount to
telling us when in presence of the
religious hypothesis that to yield to
our fear of it being err is wiser and
better than to yield to our hope that it
may be true and he says that what we
have an example of here is not the
intellect against passions but rather
the intellect being driven by one
passion against the other passion
the person who argues in favor of you
know don't make any commitments they're
driven by fear essentially fear of
falling into error or even of you
falling into error because it's not it's
not their belief that you're deciding
it's your belief what he says right say
says here we go if religion be true and
the evidence for it still be
insufficient I do not wish by putting
your extinguisher upon my nature which
feels to me as if I had after all some
business in this matter to forfeit my
sole chance in life of getting on the
winning side so that's a key aspect and
that takes us up to a certain point then
James introduces another wrinkle he
tells us that there's a further
dimension or claim of religion would
this indeed apply to all religions
perhaps not although people often want
to bring up you know examples of
Buddhism it's non-theistic well not
exactly
many forms of Buddhism are in fact
theistic and you know there is no self
true but there are persons if you're
praying to the Bodhisattva Guanyin or
trying to get yourself into the Pure
Land through faith and I meet a Buddha
that's that's a regular religious
hypotheses and that fits in with this
claim he says that one of the things
that religion tells us is that the more
perfect and more eternal aspect of the
universe is represented as having a
personal form a form we can interact
with the universe is no longer a mere it
to us but allow if we are religious and
and he says any relation that may be
possible from person to person might be
possible here notice he doesn't say is
possible might be possible so he says we
feel as if the appeal to religion to us
were made to our own active goodwill as
if evidence would be forever withheld
from us unless we met the hypothesis
way like we have to do with other
personal beings we can't just be in our
closed off bubble and demand that they
somehow permeate that and contact us we
have to go out to meet them as James
says earlier halfway when it comes to
matters of liking or loving or any other
personal relation to another being so
again he says that if the hypothesis
were true in all its parts including
this one then pure intellectualism with
its veto on our making willing advances
would be an absurdity
and some participation of our
sympathetic nature would be logically
required we would have to go out there
and extend ourselves and take a risk a
risk of falling into falsehood but the
risk that can also bring us into contact
with truth not merely possessing the
truth but being in relation to the truth
being in a personal relation with the
truth the last thing that he says is
that belief is measured by action so
because of that he says anyone who
forbids us to believe religion to be
true also forbids us to act as if we did
believe it to be true and then he goes
on and says the whole defense of
religious faith hinges upon action so
here's where James is giving us a sort
of pragmatic criterion for whether a
person really is embracing or acting
upon religious belief or faith does it
make any difference in their life in
ways that can be observed he says that
if the action required or inspired by
the religious hypothesis is in no way
different than that dictated by the
naturalistic hypothesis then religious
faith is a pure soup soup superfluity
better pruned away and controversy about
its legitimacy as a piece of idle
trifling unworthy of serious minds so if
the religious beliefs
doesn't actually make any difference in
a person's life in their behavior in
what they would do if they don't do
anything differently than they would if
they accepted the purely naturalistic
hypothesis that this is all we get and
there aren't any you know best things
that are eternal or any of that sort of
business let alone personal then it
doesn't really mean anything it doesn't
have any significance it's only when it
does lead to some modification of action
or a continuance of an action for
somebody who continues to live out a
religious faith
that it would have any significance so
James is providing us here with a
pragmatic argument for why it is that
not only should we be prepared to accept
religious belief on our own part or at
least to entertain it as a hypothesis
and then to try to see whether there's
anything there but also for the
legitimacy of other people's faith which
may have to do with very different live
options than those which appeal to us
you